rosebud's going to be at the biltmore
cabaret in vancouver at just for laughs
this saturday june 2nd through the 4th
at the improv in tempe arizona june 23rd
through the 26th at the house of comedy
in minneapolis you can get all that info
at rosebudbaker.com
yeah
um
i didn't know you were writing for snl
travis just told me you were writing for
them yeah yeah how is that because you
always hear that it's very stressful and
it's it's very competitive it's
stressful like the hours are stressful
um it's like a uh
i i don't find it to be that stressful
of a job in outside of just like the
hours right you know but i it's it's
been cool i'm learning a lot i have no
business being there i don't know what
i'm doing i have no idea how to write a
sketch
what are the hours um
all the time
just all the time like 10 am you start
maybe well no you get to start later but
like uh do you ever have to stay up late
you
you go in tuesday's wednesdays are the
worst because tuesdays you you go in
around like 1 p.m you figure out what
you're gonna write and then you start
writing at like six seven
and uh you write until like five a.m oh
wow
yeah and then you have to wake up at
like nine and do rewrites like check
everything and send it all in there's
people there that late though it's
you're not alone at four o'clock in the
morning at three o'clock it's all the
writers it's like just all the writers
are there but we're all like holed up
you know some of us are writing together
some of us are writing on our own it's
like
the weirdest
just the weirdest
situation because you the next day
you're just completely out of your mind
tired by the third week i'm always like
my teeth are going to fall out
you know my voice is always gone because
i'm constantly just chugging caffeine
yeah you know so the imposter syndrome
never
went away it's not it's not imposter
syndrome i have no business being there
i see i see this isn't like your brain
playing tricks on you this is
understanding reality i have total no
problem accepting the check i just don't
know what i'm doing this is looking up
the word imposter and going yep that's
perfect yeah yeah this is 100 accurate
i mean i like it because i i've i feel
like with stand-up
um i was just i'd put out a special and
i was getting a little bored with myself
and didn't know what i was going to talk
about next so this is kind of like a
perfect thing where i i get to figure
out something else you know like i get
to
kind of focus on this and figure out
what i'm doing wrong and finally by the
end of i got in
early march and by may it was the first
time i'd watched one of my sketches go
up and be like oh i know what i did
wrong
like
whereas normally i look at it and i go i
don't know why this isn't working but i
know it's not working you watched it go
up does that mean on the show or just a
rehearsal or even just the table reads i
can go oh i know what happened there
i i guess that's good i mean that that
shows growth right when you know
how to fix something you did wrong
that's a big deal i don't even know if i
know how to fix it okay you can just
identify but i know exactly what went
wrong like if what did you do wrong so
like i had written this sketch uh with
alex english called gay or nice it was
like a game show sketch to figure out if
a guy was like gay or nice right
and
the jokes there are you could make a lot
of jokes about whether or not a guy is
like gay or nice like if you if he calls
sandwiches sammy's right like
you know so it was like that kind of
that should have been the joke like over
and over again but we got distracted
where like this end beat where i was
like maybe she like decides she wants to
go home with the gay guy you know
regardless
that could have been like an end beat to
get out of the sketch we got distracted
i was like alex go you write the first
draft i'll do a second pass i alex
brings it back to me and it was like
the um
i think there was like a wedding in the
middle of it and i was like
i was like i think we got distracted
yeah by the side game here
and and that's the point i think yeah so
i was like well it's too late to like
rewrite this and and to do but i was
like we'll cut this down in the middle
and then maybe it'll just be like a fun
middle beat but it was too it was still
too much and so we watched it and we
were both like uh we got distracted yeah
we started having too much fun on the
side and then like forgot about the main
joke yeah we're not thinking about the
show anymore we're just having a good
time
which is what happens a lot you'll be
like oh this this one joke is funny i'm
just going to see where this goes yeah
and then you've lost the sketch you
should have ended it with something like
where someone looks the camera and goes
but all kidding aside folks adam
and eve not adam steve
we like to laugh but marriage is between
a man and a woman miley cyrus coming up
let's get the jews out of the banks
[Laughter]
so uh how much writing do you guys do
that never makes it on the air like is
it a lot
uh
or have you figured out when a bad idea
is a bad idea pretty quickly uh i feel
like now i can figure out it's always a
surprise you know
that's fun yeah like sometimes you think
something's gonna go great and then they
have that's the thing about it is it's
front of a it's in front of a live
audience so you don't
really think about that so if you have
had stuff that like
you're like yeah this is it this is the
sk and not only is this good this is the
one that people are gonna be like oh
[ __ ] you wrote that and then it goes in
front of dress rehearsal and you're like
oh
no
i'm literally i'm never like oh people
are gonna be like you wrote that if
anything i'm like please don't don't
look you know what i mean but there's
definitely ones where i'm like oh this
is absolutely gonna crush and uh it just
doesn't have you have any have you had
any bomb in the table read oh yeah
nothing but like nothing but bombs at
the table
for the most part like the first couple
weeks i was like this is
the worst thing i've ever because
there's nine pages left
skip it you can just skip next one you
know what i mean you see lauren like
checking how many pages it is like right
in front of you
[ __ ] and you realize it's like
oh no if you didn't laugh at this joke
the first time it's just that joke over
and over yeah do they ever bail on them
and go we're not going to read their no
and that's the thing that's what's so
painful it's like every one of us wants
to have like a skip button where we're
like ah just move on it's fine
but why don't we can't
they only pick of all the things that
you write that night they pick like 36
38 for the table read and then you read
through all of those that day and then
they pick the show
that day so
everything that you pick on that the
like lauren and them pick on wednesday
goes to dress
and so you can't you have to read
through every sketch just to see like
you know we're gonna do rewrites is
there something here where we could do
rewrites and make it work for us okay
sure but when it's a pass like when
something is like clearly a pass is it
quick like is it pain quick and painless
like is it just like no moving on next
one
or is it like no let's try to see
no sometimes there's something there
they'll be like there's something for
this because it is like a variety show
so you think about like
the stuff that has like a wild costume
or maybe there's like a dance number in
the middle of it and so
the show as a whole like would benefit
from having something like that so it's
not all one node right yeah
so it it depends i think i mean that's i
know no by the way i feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] because i like just got there i
don't really know the show as well your
experiences yeah yeah but that's sort of
what i'm picking up on so far it seems
terrifying yeah it was terrible was it
an intimidating thing when you when they
were like yeah you got the this is this
is you got the job i'm so happy i was so
happy i don't have to go on the road i
was like oh my god thank you
i'll stay up 72 hours in a row to not
get on a [ __ ] plane right now like
that's how it felt because i was i had
all these road dates coming up and no
idea what i wanted to talk about and no
real interest in myself and was like i
just want something to like stay home
and do right so i wasn't that
intimidated when i finally got there i
was like oh no
no this is the gig how many pages is
this a sketch just seems like an
impossible thing to write like
it's so funny because you do all that
character stuff and you're still like
i have no idea i write it i just make it
up and it bombs and i keep moving
it it's kind of like
it's it's not hard to write it's like uh
once you get the hang of the
of the thing it you know what's not
going to work and
you go okay
what's the main joke here and like
if it's if it's the same joke over and
over and over again
then you run into trouble and how many
pages is it
eight pages of sketch it doesn't have to
be it can go from like i've
seen sketches that are like 12 pages
and i'm like that's long yeah but
it can be
five to seven pages i think is like for
me i look at that and go like that's
perfect yeah like you're in and out five
minutes yeah but for the show i think it
they're usually like around 10 pages
oh my god i would survive so poorly
there you would i would just i would
literally just parasite onto somebody i
wouldn't mind taking a pass to this cat
like going over somebody's work i'm
actually good at like looking and
finding jokes in it or making
corrections because it's a fresh but
just to create one i've been aw anyone
can do that it's hard to do it's really
hard i'm like i don't know i i
i like basically would go around to the
writers that have been there for a long
time and i would walk into their office
and be like is there like a book i can
read about this like how do i figure out
what i'm doing wrong because i know i'm
doing everything wrong i just don't know
like there's jokes in my sketches that
work but the whole thing overall sucks
have you had any character ideas that
you thought were going to be good like
this would be that like you know it's
mike and he eats crackers and people
like this stinks the new opera boy
i've never had an idea for a character
in my life
yeah my brain doesn't go to that but i
the cast members do they come up and
they have ideas for characters and then
you build a sketch around that character
so they'll be like here's the character
and you're like where would that be
funny you know like where's the funny
that seems scary too though because i
feel like i would try to write a sketch
for this character and i'd be like
here's my idea and they'd go you don't
understand the character at all that's
not like this character would never do
anything they're in the room with you oh
okay so you're right going back to that
and you're like
it's this cool this is like a fun thing
that's such it's so [ __ ] dorky but
like you have your computer screen then
they have a tv on the wall behind you so
you'll be typing with the other writers
while the writers are looking at the tv
screen so they're seeing you type and
they'll be like oh and then write this
and then go back and then so you feel
like you're really making like a
painting together or something it's like
a cool oh they'll they'll see your
screen on it so it's easy they don't
have to stand over your not over your
shoulder they're sitting on the couch
next to you and they're looking at the
tv screen while you're typing and then
jim is that a porn tab oh yeah yeah
that looks like a colleague
like writing for like not that writing
for colin or or michael che they're
doing the weekend updates easy but it
seems like more traditional joke writing
that i would like more it's more yeah
traditional joke writing so you have
like topical yeah so you have a place to
start it's not just like you have a
setup an imagination thing yeah yeah
yeah it's very it's kind of cool i was
like getting my my stand up was getting
[ __ ] depressing so like being in a
place like that where everything's so
silly has been good for me yeah you know
was there any were you like
i mean everybody's a fan i think to some
extent but was it like okay this is like
iconic this is the this is a big deal it
was cool yeah it was like walking
through the hall was like
just uh
i didn't really realize until i got
there i was like just like heroes on the
wall just being like you don't deserve
to be here you know what i mean but it
was cool who do you think you are yeah
yeah it was very uh
yeah it was like that first week i was
just like what the [ __ ] what is your
first day like like when you walk into
this place and you're like i am now an
employee like i'm i'm not just taking a
tour supposed to be here i belong here i
have a little id badge like what do you
do the first day you you start you just
keep like looking down at your badge and
being like oh cool and then
looking around your office and being
like so what do i do and they're like
figure it out and you're like
just go start looking at your badge
again there's no there's nothing you
don't know about the cycle yeah
you're like
uh and everybody's very nice like they
come up and they go like i remember my
first week everyone kept coming in and
being like are you okay
and i was like yeah i'm good i'm people
keep asking me that should i not be okay
and then um
i realized they were asking that because
uh
that's the only time that they're gonna
you know
they're gonna be like are you okay the
first week and then after that it's like
figure it out yeah nobody has time to
like take care of you right a month in
you're like guys i don't know if you
were gonna check but i'm definitely not
okay i don't know if anybody can help
now i mean they would they would but
like it's very much like
new york rush hour
uh energy where it's like if you have
if there's a problem you need to go to
somebody yourself nobody's gonna like
stop and be like you seem like you're
maybe you're going through something you
know
because and it's that's for the benefit
of the show because you gotta make
you're making the show in a week right
you write the show in one night well
yeah it's like yeah you don't have
necessarily time to because you came in
halfway through the season right or did
you start at the beginning of the season
no i came in halfway through the season
i was like so it's like the wheels are
already moving yeah it's like come on
you gotta come in and start writing
episodes with us yeah immediately yeah
which is amazing because they're about
they're going to start a new season and
you're going to be like a tenured you're
not going to be the new kid anymore i
definitely not going to be tenured but
that'd be two you know like a new person
would come in and go like oh you're
somebody who's right it feels like okay
at least i got my sea legs a little bit
right and you're gonna be like no i'm
i'm also a new person i have no idea
yeah
yeah and then producing your [ __ ] is
different too like you get this bird's
eye view of like how not only how do i
how is this going to get made but how is
it going to look right where are people
going to stand because the writers
produce their [ __ ] like your sketch gets
picked you
like you sit with the director and you
go can we get like a two shot here and
can we get like when she does this punch
line can we like spike the camera to
like get a closer shot so you know which
shots are funnier for what like you
start to learn that [ __ ] and that's a
whole other level of like understanding
that you
don't have when you go in there and when
you're like i'm like thank god i got
this job before i got my own show that's
why snl writers and people who work
there really go on to be able to
creative and do a lot of [ __ ] because i
guess you get such training in every
area that you wouldn't think of yeah at
the end you're doing so much paid to go
to harvard that's what it feels like
right and it's got to be terrible though
when you're watching like i hate
watching myself so much and watching
anything you do bomb has got i'm sure
again it's a part of it it's a sketch
show it's not gonna not happen have you
had anything bomb in front of an
audience
um
i've had like pre-tapes where i was like
i didn't do what i wanted it to do is it
humiliating or is everybody so used to
it no one cares like it's it's like i
would walk around humiliating every time
every [ __ ] time
it gets better yeah i'll like leave to
go like i'll i will not sit in the
writers room while my sketch is on like
i'll go down to the floor to watch it
i'm not gonna sit in the room with the
writers and be like
here we go let's see how it does and
then it just starts to bomb and
everybody gets quiet and they go like
well i liked it you know
like it's just the worst that happens
all right yeah all the time by the way
we should go to tom in new hampshire
because i've been beating myself up ever
since i said it and i think this is the
only thing that'll make it better okay i
don't know if i've caught it but uh i
100 caught it as soon as i said it
what's up what happened
what happened yes it's opera man not
opposite voice i said oh i didn't i said
opera boy and as soon as i said i was
like you [ __ ] idiot yeah thank god
tom was here to point out i never i
didn't know the character opera man
played by
he also adam the water boy and clearly
yeah i understand you made the mistake i
made a mistake
i made a mistake i feel like we can get
past it yeah though yeah
because clearly it was bothering
everybody not just me yeah um so does
the head writers michael is the head
writer right he's one of the head
writers one of them so those guys as
head writers do they like will people
walk in with sketches and go can you
help with this or like do they have
final say what does being a head writer
there mean other than just i have no
idea i think it's like a totally
different thing i mean it's not but it
seems like it is because they're
they're writing
uh
they're they're the most experienced
there so there's that so they're writing
the majority of the show is like head
writers you know like they're
they're doing a lot more and they'll and
you can
work on something with a head writer
uh to get their guidance and stuff but i
i truly don't know
what it is but they go over sketches and
everything it's not just their own
they're in every meeting you know what i
mean they're like it's more than just
the writing it's like they're
in the meetings they're talking about
the show and what what it should look
like and what you know they're
they're in the meetings with lauren
where is like after the table read
whereas like we just go back to our like
offices and wait there like choir boys
right like t defeat did that i know for
a while she was a head writer and
there's always really funny people and i
guess a lot of time the weekend update
person ends up being the head writer is
that i don't know i honestly don't know
i make sense though because they said
but again they're just doing this joke
joke
yeah yeah
but i don't know i mean i guess
was norm ever a head writer there i
don't know i don't know colin i'm not
sure if colin ever was i don't think
colin was
yeah i guess i don't know norm and colin
also seem like they're writing their own
voice a lot right
yeah yeah yeah
i'm just fascinated by snl though
i've never been with taping i might want
to go to a taping someday like
i've never just never done saturday
night you know come on i mean i'm busy
i have plenty of time oh yeah dress
rehearsal live show whatever whatever
whatever yeah yeah back in 2007 i had no
time now plenty of times
can i go twice in a row
yeah but i've never seen it live and i
think i would like to once just go to a
taping and watch it happen it just seems
it terrifies me the sketches are so
scary because you're committed when
you're in it yeah you're buying it as a
stand-up you know if you're [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] you just you can maneuver
and address it and break the fourth wall
you can say something yeah but it's also
like it's not you that's up there so you
know like it's your fault like if
they're if they're bombing it's your
fault
like and they're stuck there so they
just so you feel bad on a level where
you're like this isn't even me taking
the beating no but i would feel it
depend on who it was like if i was
writing for snl and bob kelly was a cast
member
all i would do is try to set him up to
fail oh bob trust me this is gonna work
it's gonna work no one's gonna laugh if
i do that bob trust me it's good stuff
well when it's your friend's bombing
it's like it's it's great it's great but
when it's somebody you just met and it's
like you just started working with them
you're like [ __ ] we're the guest host
who's your first guest host
first guest host uh mullany was the
first one when i was there yeah you can
go to rosebudbaker.com for tickets and
dates and all that stuff